[music]
you know, it seems to me that our
Ukrainian people will already have enough peaceful
skies over their heads, we are a strong nation, we will
rebuild Ukraine anew, well, the main thing is
that shells do not fly planes to
finish it all in the
bushes on the sheet, they will come out earlier,
coins will come from us tomorrow  after another tor
here, a month later, I was in forgiveness
for being other domains
just across countries and you
remember the red day yourself writes and kwang enlightened
iksha
throw off the loduca of his shabak further she is a
masochine of Ukraine nikolay for any
russian
[music]
need
barrels remained there with  the son is older and
stayed alive this journalists want me to go
to war with kim together
so we want to return from conveniently
[music]
and yves rocher corrected your number 6 act of
war and before the new
log cabins she and the world do not clipart
[music]
you reflect it  art
love snarling plant you export your
from the body of the century at the old chic from
convinced her new
[music]
yes you appeared on or dynamite work
[  music]
from here rooftops
[music]